two convicted criminals addicted to
drugs with two very different paths in
life
i come out of jail with 40 pounds
because that's what you get
truthfully around the dealer
so we turned up they gave me the six
white and
it just starts again and again and again
and again and again
when i got out on the first of april i
had a script in mind for the saturday
and sunday and an appointment already
made on monday
one released into a system prepared to
support and provide treatment
the other left in a vulnerable
life-threatening situation when i was a
little kid in the asking school what do
you want to be believe me i did not say
a crackhead i did not say a drug addict
a substance user
the difference isn't necessarily their
crime or sentence
but simply where they live it's
absolutely possible to copy and paste
what we have here and the engagement
into the community treatment
can be replicated in any area across the
country and we know it makes a
difference
and with a lack of resources and
partnership in most of the country the
consequences can be fatal
that's what killed brandon
not having that support
so how are you expected to break the
cycle of drugs and crime if it's left to
a cruel postcode lottery
when he was released from prison joe had
no other choice than to return here the
streets of manchester with limited or no
support available for his drug addiction
he was back taking lethal substances
i got out on the third of march this
year
and i got promised all these options
would be available when i got out but
then when it actually came to the
limelight there was only one choice and
you know what that was coming back to
this city center homeless doing drugs
manchester city there's like a breeding
ground for it yeah there's no escaping
it because you'll say to yourself one
morning oh yeah what i get off drugs but
then you'll see somebody later who's
selling drugs taking drugs off issue
drugs it's just a circle and it never
ends
just two hours down the road in the west
midlands and that vicious drug cycle for
elton is long gone his path out of
prison was the complete opposite i've
got my prescription which the prisoners
gave me for the weekend until my
appointment
i've always
self-destructed when bad things have
happened in my personal life i always
ended up back on drugs using that as a
a crotch basically to get through
but this time i've literally put walls
around me of support so that any any
problem any issue i've got
they're there straight away
elton fell into a system that provides
stability
from help with housing to daily doses of
methadone which keeps him off lethal
substances
thanks a lot see you tomorrow
and a weekly meeting with this
caseworker gun appointment
keeps him on track without the i've been
ratting him basically i'll be back using
drugs straight away offending straight
away
i'd have no other choice
yeah i'll have a show at breakfast by
nine
college for ten the problem is in
england there aren't many cases like
elton he's a part of a small and lucky
group of people however like joe there
are thousands of prison leavers across
the country that need the support and
treatment but it's just not an option
a massive proportion of england's
prisoners are known to have drug
problems
data shared with sky news suggests 25
000 prisoners are leaving jail with drug
issues and across england only 38 of
them are receiving support for it that
means around two-thirds of england's
prisoners are leaving jail and could be
going straight back into a dangerous
life of drugs
if we look at manchester the number of
prisoners receiving support here is
lower than the national average at just
23.8 percent it's amongst the worst in
the country but results in sandwell are
completely different 49 of prison
leavers got vital help in 2021 but
latest data shared with us takes that
number to 62 percent one of the best
performing areas in the country
you know if i could get that help do you
really think i'd be sat in front of the
tent do you really think i'd be wasting
my time yeah trying to explain how much
of a system is because if the system
wasn't i wouldn't be talking this right
this second
for some what happens in the hours after
leaving prison can be the difference
between life and death
well from the minute that i came out of
these gates he picked him up he escorted
him to the patient to see his probation
officer
he waited for him
and he took him to his new accommodation
in stanley street
and that was it
brandon was just 23 years old when he
was released from prison in manchester
that same night he died from drug misuse
well it was ten to one
and the phone went the house phone went
and it was his mum
telling me that brandon was dead
and
i just was screaming
screaming
i just couldn't believe what maze was
eating
his family say that hours after leaving
prison brandon realized his shelter was
unsupervised and so he left to find
drugs the following morning he was lying
in a corridor dying of a cocaine
overdose
no words could express how much you miss
him
he wasn't discovered until hours later
there was no help for him
you know
there was nobody even to phone an
ambulance he lay there for hours
who knows if he'd about
an ambulance who knows he could have
survived
but here we are now
if you said to me you needed help i
couldn't say oh there's a center there's
a place you can go but it's nowhere
you know you've either got to do it
yourself
or you're left
to end up like
this death by drug misuse rates across
england have increased year on year
from 3.9 in 2015 to 5 deaths per 100 000
people in 2020
again manchester's numbers are worse
than the national average with 9 in
every 100 000 people dying from drug
misuse and again sandwell are performing
considerably better 2.2 deaths per 100
000 are caused by drug misuse that's
less than half the national average
so the question is how is a place like
sandwell despite its everyday challenges
offering people here a lifeline
so the cranston team are just there on
the right
uh drug testing happens across the
corridor just there and then as you can
see this is the main bit this is where
you bought when you're first arrested um
in westminster how crucial is it being
so nearby it's unique because this is
our first point of contact with people
who use drugs this is where we can get
to them
meg heads up an organization that is
ingrained in sandwell's response to
drugs
cranston works with the council the nhs
and west midlands police to rehabilitate
drug users from the moment they're
arrested
we feel it's really important to have a
whole system approach right from
pre-arrest where we have a diversion
scheme for people finding possession of
drugs to the police custody where we are
today and our service exists across the
westminster police right through to our
community service in in samwell which
picks people up
from coming out of prison so someone
will come in
and be checked into the the desk here
and our team will either do voluntary
sweeps of cells
you're right dan
i'm dave i'm a drug and hardcore worker
i drop an alcohol worker if you've got
any addiction issues or actually if
someone has come in uh through a serious
acquisitive crime something like
burglary or shoplifting um then they may
be um asked to do a drug test
you know you're sitting in the police
cell you've
got nobody no contact no nothing and
then they're there willing to help you
straight away
this super block of cells functions in a
completely unique way to the rest of the
country no other local authority has a
system in place to intercept offenders
on arrest and provide drug treatment
right through to when they leave prison
so why isn't this formula which we know
is effective happening across the
country
it's absolutely possible to copy and
paste what we have here and the
engagement into the community treatment
can be replicated in any area across the
country it would reduce drug-related
deaths it would get more people into
treatment it would save money to society
so we would really want to look at
and ask government to look at the model
that we've got here and empower the
local authorities to come together to
work together
to build the same sort of model across
the country
but the government told us different
areas have different challenges and so
they can't endorse a one-size-fits-all
approach success isn't necessarily down
to money but how different authorities
work together to deliver an effective
service all to evident at cranston's
headquarters
okay no worries that's okay bye bye
samwell council the nhs and samwell has
always had a big focus on drug addiction
alcohol-related harm so that's important
this work is resource intensive and
we could always do with more funding and
it's a cost-effective spend if we can
help someone back off drugs that
that reduces costs for the whole of
society it reduces crime
it would be shooting ourselves in the
foot as a society to not support this
group of people out of those problems
and back into maybe
a more functioning role in society
the drug and alcohol workers here aren't
just meeting people at police stations
or at the prison gates simon takes
life-saving supplies to people on the
streets it's face-to-face engagement
which proves vital we need to get out
there and meet people where they're at
some people might be facing so many
barriers
that just getting to our service getting
into the office in the first place
maybe several steps away
we're getting people using heroin down
here
but also people are using this as a
space to come and smoke weed pretty much
all of this litter here is drug related
so you've got packets for syringes
packets for needles
needle casings
cookers
but this level of engagement in a city
like manchester is limited the
partnership work is lacking and so the
drug problem here is ever present
it's often in the stairwells of these
big multi-story car parks where we know
people are taking drugs from heroin to
crack to spice and that there is the
reality if there are no or limited
options for drug addicts to seek
treatment when they're released from
prison and here in manchester where the
engagement levels are so low charities
are trying to help but with lack of
resources and partnership the knock-on
effects to wider society are
they huge out of jail and they come to
us and say oh i've just got out of jail
i need clothing i need this that and the
other some of them do get accommodation
but when they go into the accommodation
there's no support whatsoever so these
you might as well just be back out on
the streets and
straight back to the crack and the spice
straight away yeah drop the tea bag take
it out
despite having one of the worst records
in the country manchester city council
told us they're pleased with the number
of people engaging with treatment upon
leaving prison but added making sure
there is a clear and supportive pathway
is a key part of the work the council
does to help people recover from
substance misuse we know there is more
that can be done to support what is a
very vulnerable cohort
this is a long-standing issue which is
only now getting the attention it needs
from government they've declared a new
120 million pound fund to crack down on
addiction by rolling out 18
abstinence-led drug wings in prisons to
get offenders clean and recruiting 50
health and justice coordinators across
the country to improve links between
prisons and community treatment services
but their biggest commitment ensuring
every offender will have access to
treatment they need and a plan to help
them turn their backs on crime are empty
words to people like joe until he sees
that change
i
i drop every single drug in the world if
i could get proper help
i want to be a role model for my little
brother and sister
but while i'm on drugs i can't you know
and because i know in my head i can't do
that and the addictions got me i say
more and more and more
we've granted in this time it's been
more like a circuit breaker and instead
of self-destructing of using it to
using the bad things that have happened
to
turn them into positives and build
myself
differently this time
could have found coming off without him
but
without him i know that i'd be still on
drugs and still offend him and if not in
prison or dead
you